[Music]
yeah that's happening right there
bachelor nation in shock and awe today
after corinne and mario clearly put the
scandal in paradise behind them uh
clearly e.t online's lauren zema with
corrine today and she got to the bottom
of their late night club reunion
what was that like to see him i'm really
glad we got to hang out finally and just
like
be our normal selves
actually
i will
did you text him i did karen and mario
were out having dinner and drinks last
night with the rest of the paradise cast
corrin wrapping her legs around demario
reminiscent of the infamous pool
incident that shut down production for
the first time in bachelor history why
did you have to stay quiet for so long
or why did you want to what happened was
kind of really private and yeah i
actually told him last night i was like
you ran to the media i'm so mad at you
and he was like no i didn't like i only
went to the media after your statement
came out i was upset that we couldn't
have just handled it privately at the
core of the misconduct allegations an
unnamed producer who felt things had
gotten out of hand corrine and dimario
were both cleared of any wrongdoing so
what really happened corrine says
drinking while on prescription drugs led
to a blackout so you feel like that
producer's intentions were good yes
yes of course after the fact i i guess i
was expressing that i didn't even
remember talking to damario
and that's when they were like okay
like this is
we gotta do something about this what is
next for you i'm still working on my
book it's actually coming together
amazing
and i'm working on some scripted tv
stuff
[Music]